the show opens up in Damascus Syria
where the infamous terrorist
organization the Islamic State AKA Isis
is slowly advancing they are attempting
to bombard the city and make it their
own although the entire world knows of
this no one dares to intervene and the
innocent people of Damascus are left to
live in fear one day in the midst of all
the chaos an unidentified man clad in
yellow is preaching to a crowd urging
them to stay calm he tells them that
they need not worry about the Islamic
State as the fate of Damascus has been
divinely ordained as the Islamic state
begins firing upon the city from their
vantage point on the outskirts of
Damascus the people brace themselves for
the worst however before the enemy can
breach the city's walls a massive
Sandstorm of biblical proportions
descends upon Damascus enveloping it in
a thick blanket of dust the sandstorm
rages for an entire month effectively
isolating the city from the outside
world the roads and airports are
rendered impassable businesses are
forced to shut down and the people are
left to struggle in the face of this
natural disaster yet in a surprising
turn of events the sandstorm also proves
to be damascus's salvation the Islamic
State's supply lines are disrupted and
they are forced to retreat from the city
defeated and humiliated the scene then
cuts to a fertility clinic where CIA
case officer Eva Geller is recovering
from yet another miscarriage she is
evidently devastated but she collects
herself and returns to work there she
learns about the preacher who has now
gained popularity after correctly
predicting that Damascus will not fall
to Isis he is hailed as a messiah and
people have named him al-massi it is
also revealed that he is amassed more
than 2 000 followers consisting mostly
of displaced Palestinians currently he
is leading them to a desert among the
followers is an orphan boy named jibril
who is fascinated by Alma C's knowledge
and wisdom although the real identity
and motive of the preacher is unknown
his growing influence worries Geller and
she keeps a close eye on him later that
day almasi and his followers set up camp
to spend the night gibril finally gets
to interact with him and manages to
become his favorite soon the CIA gets to
know that almasi is leading the refugees
to the Israeli border they scramble to
alert Israeli authorities while the
preacher's followers vow to fight the
Jewish State however al-massi stuns his
followers when he orders everyone to
collect their weapons and bury them
although puzzled they eventually oblige
and follow him to the Border after a
while as expected the Israeli Army stops
the group and arrests almasi for trying
to infiltrate the Jewish State Geller
requests the American under Secretary of
the Middle East to let her interrogate
amaci but he declines saying it's none
of America's business the scene then
cuts to the home of aviram Dahan who
works for the shinbat Israeli
International Security Agency he is
always occupied with work which caused
the breakdown of his marriage with his
ex-wife later aviram begins
interrogating MSC and to his surprise
the mysterious man responds in fluent
Hebrew despite his expertise aviram is
unable to get a clear answer from Al
Messi who claims to be on a Divine
mission to deliver a message from his
father as the interrogation continues
the preacher astounds aviram by calling
him by his real name Al Messi also
correctly predicts that aviram is
hurting internally because of an
incident that happened with a young boy
and megido during a shinbat operation
hearing all this the agent abruptly ends
the interrogation and deletes the
recording from shinbat records in the
next scene aviram meets his close friend
and inquires if he had ever mentioned
the megiddo incident to anyone the
latter assures that he would never do
such a thing with this consolation
aviram decides to continue his
interrogation at 3am in the morning
however to his astonishment he learns
that almasi has escaped from detention
following this we are taken to Dilly
Texas where a young girl named Rebecca
is seen smoking a cigarette by herself
in a field her father Felix iguero is
the town's Pastor the Aguero family is
currently going through financial
hardships and they are struggling to pay
off their debts this has caused friction
in Mr and Mrs aguero's marriage as the
former refuses to seek help from his
father-in-law as the news of Alma sees
Escape spreads tensions rise among the
people he had led to Israel's border who
now face starvation and uncertainty the
International Community watches with
concern fearing the potential for a
larger crisis to unfold meanwhile Geller
finally receives clearance from her
superiors and travels to Israel she is
determined to uncover the truth behind
amazi's extraordinary abilities and his
mysterious message upon arrival Geller
is allowed to attend a debriefing of
aviram the officials are shocked as
almasi managed to escape just two
minutes after aviram entered the
Detention Facility they are even more
Disturbed to learn that the security
cameras in the Cell Block were
mysteriously Switched Off for a crucial
12-minute period during which the
prisoner made his Escape despite their
suspicions aviram maintains his
innocence and insists that the deleted
tape contained nothing of significance
meanwhile the news of almasi's Escape
reaches his followers at the border and
they become further resolved to stay a
paranoid aviram feels like he's being
set up so he picks up his daughter from
her play school fearing for her safety
however as he drives around with her he
notices a man resembling almasi in the
crowd determined to get to the bottom of
this he leaves his daughter in the car
and follows the man only to realize that
he was mistaken in the next scene the
real Embassy shows up at the temple
mouth in Jerusalem and starts preaching
a sermon to the crowd he says that these
steps to the holy Place have been
stained with the blood of Brothers
killing each other for far too long but
now that time has ended history has
ended Al Messi claims the Judgment Day
is here when the almighty will judge
everyone's Souls soon the Israeli police
catch wind of the sermon and they move
to capture almasi however they are
forced to stay put when someone
seemingly fires a gun from the crowd and
a boy ends up getting hurt Panic ensues
and the boy's mother accuses the
Israelis of shooting him but right then
Alma C lays hands on the boy and
miraculously brings him to life the
latter even Rises up and displays a
bloody Bullet to the crowd as expected
everyone hails this as a miracle but
before they can interrogate almasi he
disappears Into Thin Air a few hours
later the news of the amaci and his
mysterious Escape finally gets out in
the media and fresh riots start in
Jerusalem over the shooting to contain
the violence the Israeli police seal the
Temple Mount and hold the people back
back in Damascus after almasi doesn't
come into contact with his followers at
the border some of them begin to get
Restless they wonder if he has abandoned
them for good but the group Elder urges
them to remain faithful and not act out
of foolish despair in the meantime
aviram is approached by Geller who asks
him about the deleted interrogation tape
but he refuses to tell her anything
afterwards Geller hires local Israeli
agents including her old friend Kamar to
help her investigate they examine the
footage from the shooting but fail to
locate anyone firing the gun hence
Galler begins to suspect that the entire
episode may have been a charade and the
boy who was shot might be in on it to
get to the bottom of the truth she
drives to East Jerusalem with Kamar to
find the Arab boy however they learned
that the boy has already left with his
family fearing for his safety meanwhile
pressure starts to mount on the Israeli
authorities as they refuse to allow the
refugees into its country at the border
an Arab woman from Israel covertly gives
food to jibril assuring him that they
will be fine surprisingly aviram is
watching it all transpire and after the
woman leaves he kidnaps the boy
following this we are again taken to
Texas where the teenager Rebecca packs
her bags and runs away from home after a
few hours her father Felix wakes up in
the middle of the night and strangely
goes to a gas station he then collects
some gas in a canister and heads towards
the church intending to Burn It To The
Ground back in his room Felix's phone
starts bursting with notifications of a
tornado warning waking up his wife Anna
when she reads the warning she
frantically rushes to find both Rebecca
and Felix but to no avail suddenly the
town's Air Raid Sirens begin to wail and
Anna finally finds Felix inside the
church the two start to worry as their
daughter is nowhere to be found with
each passing moment the tornado grows
stronger tearing through buildings into
uprooting trees leaving a trail of
Destruction in its wake as the husband
wife Duo go out looking for Rebecca they
suddenly spot a mysterious figure
standing amidst the chaos he is none
other than an alma see he must have
heard about how good the barbecue is
here later on a video of almasi rescuing
Rebecca is uploaded on the internet and
in no time the CIA gets wind of this
Geller immediately orders her fellow
agents to take the video down so that it
doesn't become viral she is perplexed as
to how almasi made it to America the
scene then cuts to a federal agent from
The Joint terrorism task force named
will who drives to Dilly Texas he is
taken aback to see the damage the
tornado is Left Behind it is then
revealed that the only building left
untouched was the church and inside our
almacy and Felix he explains to Felix
that he has come by God's Will and
complements his church Felix is shaken
as he realizes that he was trying to
burn down the very building which saved
a lot of lives all of a sudden will
enters the church and arrests almasi
Felix is left infuriated but he promises
to get the preacher out soon in the
meantime aviram interrogates gibral with
the hopes of getting information on the
messiah's whereabouts however the boy
honestly replies that he doesn't know
anything about him aviram is confused as
to why so many people choose to follow
the preacher despite not knowing who he
is back in Dilly Rebecca reveals to her
mother that she was hiding under a rail
overpass in the drains when suddenly she
saw the Messiah standing in front of her
afterwards Anna approaches Felix outside
the church and informs him of everything
in response he says that none of the
things that have happened are a
coincidence meanwhile Geller arrives in
Texas and gets permission from the CIA
director to Quest genomicy on the way to
her hotel she checks the internet to see
if the video of the Messiah has surfaced
through her relief it hasn't however
upon arriving at the jail where Al Messi
is currently detained she receives some
bad news the federal agent will informs
her that Alma sees American civil
liberties union lawyer has banned any
outside contact with the authorities
this means that Geller won't be able to
question him much to her dismay that
night the situation worsens when another
video of the Messiah and his appearance
during the Texas tornado goes viral
meanwhile almasi finally meets his
lawyer from alcu and has a serious chat
the latter mentions that while the
charge of his illegal entry into the U.S
is likely to be upheld in court she
thinks she can get him out of jail time
shortly after will arrives at the
detention center and calls Geller he
arranges a meeting between the two as
Alma sees a lawyer has already left not
wanting to waste this opportunity Yeller
rushes to the detention Center and meets
almasi for the first time the two then
interact with each other with a very
calm demeanor Geller gives a long
monologue where she mentions that she
knows people like him people who have
become so committed to the idea of God
that they begin to embody him this is
what makes people like almasi so
dangerous the latter listens to this
carefully and turns it around on Geller
by mentioning that she worships her job
and is an acolyte of the CIA out of
nowhere things take a twisted turn as
the Messiah goes on to reveal deeply
personal things about Geller he talks
about her loneliness the death of her
mother and her husband and how she's
currently in pain despite being shaken
up Geller tries to maintain her ground
but eventually leaves the room as it
becomes overwhelming it is then revealed
that will had been recording their
entire conversation as a result Geller
begins to think that the man could be
part of a counterintelligence agency
because of the deep and personal
information he has on her the same night
back in her hotel room she reveals to
her boss that that Israel is seeking to
extradite almasi and that the state's
attorney will argue that this be allowed
so she explains about how the U.S must
detain him on American soil to extract
more information the next day Al Messi's
first hearing takes place where he is
denied Baal the judge mentions that the
next hearing will take place the
following week as the days pass almasi's
trial becomes a political issue with
people arguing about his true intentions
on live television even on channels like
CNN back in Dilly the destruction the
tornado left in its wake is devastating
and Felix and his family offer to help
those in need it turns out that many
people from all over the country have
begun to camp in Dilly to see where the
Miracle Man AKA Alma C appeared when
Felix hears the news about the messiah's
first hearing he decides to leave town
to be with him on the day of his second
hearing Felix is also present along with
Geller almacy then makes a statement
explaining about how he walks with all
men and has no religion he also talks
about the idea of borders and countries
this stirs up a lot of media attention
and also jeopardizes his chances of
winning the case because of this some
high-ranking officials decide to evict
him out of the country elsewhere it is
revealed that aviram had let go of
gibril and dropped him off in the middle
of the desert to die the poor boy walks
for Miles without any water and
eventually collapses due to exhaustion a
few days later he finally regains
Consciousness after his friends find him
in the desert meanwhile aviram has a
meeting with his boss who demands that
he confess about the contents of the
interrogation tape with Alma C which has
been erased when aviram refuses he is
stripped of his job and asked to hire a
lawyer in the following hearing the
judge makes an unbiased decision and
offers almasi asylum in Texas this means
that he will be a free man now the
episode ends as Alma C leaves with Felix
ready to ignite more controversy if you
want to watch the next part of the
series click on part two